y seguimos con nuestra serie de los
recicladores indispensables pero no
invisibles hoy vamos a españa donde
miles de personas migrantes se dedican a
recoger chatarra en las calles de
barcelona como modo de subsistencia este
reportaje hace parte de la serie de
publicaciones el resultado de la beca de
producción periodística sobre reciclaje
inclusivo ejecutada con el apoyo de la
fundación gabo y latitud r este es un
informe de judí de alonso massa y si
javier su ley
héctor tiene 28 años y lleva 3
recogiendo chatarra en las calles de
barcelona es una de las miles de
personas que sobreviven con esta
actividad en la que un buen día de
trabajo pueden llegar a ganar hasta 15
euros
aunque es español aquí la mayoría de los
recicladores son personas migrantes sin
papeles procedentes de áfrica
sub-sahariana
que buscan normalmente la chatarra o
gente que duerme en la calle o
extranjeros que no tienen recursos y
desde hace mucho desde hace cinco años
atrás ahora hay mucho el doble de gente
buscando que antes héctor vende los
materiales a karim un senegalés que
llegó a españa en 2006 empezó siendo
chatarrero y ahora gestiona está
chatarrería donde cada día recibe cerca
de 200 recicladores para escoger una
cara de 300 kilos el campus no va hasta
aquí cuando escuela metro va a ser tú
más duro
y los 365 días tu no para no es duro
encima no puedes ganar algo para decir
que tengo dinero no es duro es muy duro
para sobrevivir llegó aquí lo tengo
papel no puede trabajar esta población
invisible contribuye a el sector de
reciclaje de metales que mueve 10 mil
millones de euros al año en españa se
estima que aportan casi una tercera
parte de la chatarra que se recicla en
cataluña no obstante nadie sabe cuántos
hay ni cuál es su contribución a la
economía están fuera del sistema
institucional de reciclaje pero se
consciente su actividad dan un servicio
a la sociedad de forma gratuita porque
las empresas privadas cobran para
recoger gestionar transportar y reciclar
esos materiales y los legisladores
informales de alguna forma hacen algo
parecido pero no cobran nada del estado
y claramente hacen un servicio que
también es un servicio ambiental para
federico de maría una opción sería
formalizar los siguiendo el ejemplo de
algunos lugares de américa latina a
través de cooperativas
y las miles de personas que sobreviven
de la chatarra en la ciudad sería un
paso adelante